13.8 billion years ago the universe
began
in one moment there was nothing and the
next
everything just how this is possible is
perhaps the biggest question in all of
science crossing the boundaries between
Theory and experiment physics and
philosophy everything we know about our
universe hinges on mechanism process and
causality we strive to understand the
reasons things are the way they are and
yet at the most fundamental level we do
not know how or why the entire universe
came to be
[Music]
but this lack of explanation is not for
want of searching
perhaps as famed cosmologist Stephen
Hawking once supposed there really was
nothing before considering space and
time as inherent conjoined properties of
the universe we inhabit the beginning of
that Universe marked the beginning of
time before time there could be no space
and therefore no Universe considering
the geometry of space-time back through
the ages he saw it contract curve around
and eventually round off searching for
something beyond that would be as
meaningless as searching for something
that was north of the North Pole
or perhaps there was no actual beginning
but rather a limit to our powers of
observation scientists believe that it
was a split-second period of exponential
expansion known as inflation that put
the bang in the Big Bang and which set
the stage for everything that was to
follow our inflation stopped after a
tiny fraction of a second but some
physicists have argued that this is not
the only period of inflation in the
cosmos as a whole rather inflation would
continue elsewhere
eternally producing bubble universes
distributed through a potent Everlasting
Multiverse
or perhaps our current universe is
merely the latest in a long and
potentially infinite series of expanding
and Contracting Cosmos a theory known as
the big bounce in this instead of
starting from nothing and inflating
exponentially to reduce the structure we
see today contemporary physicists like
Paul steinhardt suggest a cyclical
growth and contraction of everything
within the universe or perhaps our
understanding of scale is fundamentally
incomplete physicist Roger Penrose
considered the properties of shapes
regardless of their size and believes we
can do the same with the cosmos in this
idea the universe loses a sense of time
and scale at the infinitely small and
the infinitely big and becomes to all
intents and purposes equivalent the game
of chess played the same whether on a
board that fits in your pockets or spans
an entire Courtyard
or perhaps our Cosmos came about as a
transient Collision of Dimensions String
Theory attempts to explain the
fundamentals of reality as Tiny
vibrating strings within an
11-dimensional reality of hyperspace the
three dimensions of space and one
dimension of time that we experience
within our Cosmos are merely a single
brain in the overall bulk with the
beginning and growth of our universe
coming about as higher order brains
collide
or perhaps there is something else
some corner of mathematics or physics
that we have yet to shine a light into
and which for the time being eludes our
understanding
for now our universe's origin story
remains a mystery a multiple choice
Choose Your Own Adventure
nevertheless
13.8 billion years ago the universe did
begin
and this is the story
of what happened next
[Music]
thank you to betterhelp for sponsoring
this video this is Proxima Centauri even
if we traveled at more than 50 000
kilometers an hour it would still take
us more than eighty thousand years to
arrive there and it is our closest star
it's estimated there are a hundred
thousand million more distant stars in
the Milky Way and so sometimes it can be
overwhelming to square our own lives
with the vastness of everything else and
to work these things through it's nice
to have some help better help is the
world's largest therapy service and it's
100 online with better help you can tap
into a network of over 30 000 licensed
and experienced therapists who can help
you with a wide range of issues you can
talk to your therapist however you feel
comfortable whether it's via text chat
or video call you can also message your
therapist at any time and schedule live
sessions when it's convenient for you
and if your therapist isn't the right
fit for any reason you can switch to a
new one at no additional charge with
better help you get the same
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but with a
therapist who is custom picked for you
with more scheduling flexibility and at
a more affordable price so get 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com
forward slash hotu and I've also linked
them Below in the description thanks to
betterhelp for supporting educational
content on YouTube
where is the hottest place in the
universe
you might expect to find it in the
natural Fusion reactor at the center of
a star but even as you incinerate in the
plunge through its fiery depths your
journey would be in vain temperatures of
the core reach a mere 15 million degrees
Celsius you may look to even more
violent phenomena in the cosmos like
explosive supernovae here during the
dramatic death of a star superheated
shells of gas are ejected many light
years in every direction leaving a
gravitationally compactified neutron
star at their Center temperatures here
are far exceed normal Stellar furnaces
reaching 100 billion degrees Celsius but
this still isn't the hottest temperature
to be found in fact the highest
temperature that has ever been recorded
anywhere in our vast Cosmos was 100
meters beneath the snow-covered ground
near the shores of Lake Lamont in
Switzerland
foreign and it didn't come about from a
natural process but rather the concerted
efforts of hundreds of scientists and
billions of euros worth of research and
development in cern's Large Hadron
Collider were individual particles are
routinely smashed into one another at
velocities approaching the speed of
light the Collision of two lead atoms in
2012 briefly produced a temperature of
around 5.5 trillion degrees Celsius 50
times hotter than a supernova
but this still isn't even close to the
highest possible temperature
temperature is little more than a
manifestation of a particle's energy its
motion or how fast it's vibrating
absolute zero marking zero Kelvin is the
lowermost limit where particles
hypothetically would come to a complete
shuddering stop were it possible to
reach but there was also an upper limit
to an absolute heart that marks the
highest temperature before the particles
themselves are torn apart by their own
energy it's known as the Planck
temperature and it is around 1.4 times
10 to the 32 Kelvin Max Planck who gave
his name to this impossibly blistering
temperature was a German theoretical
physicist who found his academic stride
around the beginning of the 20th century
his ideas are seen as the founding
blocks of quantum physics and led to the
quantization of light into discrete
chunks of energy called photons but they
also led him to consider the fundamental
quanta of other natural phenomena
using such Universal qualities as the
speed of light and the force of gravity
in combination with his eponymous Planck
constant he defined the Planck length
the smallest Quantum of distance as
around 1.6 times 10 to the minus 35
meters about 100 quintillion times
smaller than a proton the time it takes
for light to travel through this
minuscule distance through a vacuum is
the Planck time amounting to 5.39 times
10 to the minus 44 seconds and the
Planck temperature that practical
measure of absolute heat is the
temperature at which the wavelength of
thermal radiation reaches the Planck
diameter it can go no smaller
it is no fair reflection on the human
brain to say that these numbers are
beyond our true comprehension we are
evolutionarily attuned to scales that
are relevant to us and so it may seem
that these Planck units are too small or
in the case of temperature too large to
be of any practical use but it is when
contemplating the immeasurably tiny
moment at the beginning of our
immeasurably vast Cosmos that these
units really come into their own
because our universe is expanding
becoming less dense and it has been for
all its history scientists don't know if
our universe is infinite or not but if
it is then it always has been so rather
than starting as a single point it would
have also begun infinitely large and
rather than grow over time it would
simply have become less dense our
observable universe the only part of the
universe we could ever see or interact
with or could ever see and interact with
us is limited by the speed of light and
the distance it has been able to travel
since the universe's birth 13.8 billion
years ago but as we travel back in time
the observable part of the universe
shrinks and becomes more compact until
eventually we get to a time when
everything within it was only a single
Planck unit of time old a single Planck
length in diameter and with all of our
observable universe compacted into such
a tiny space that temperature of the
whole Cosmos SATs squarely
Planck temperatures
it may come as little surprise to learn
that this moment 100 million trillion
trillion trillionths of a second after
the beginning of time and space is
therefore known as the Planck error
and it is a very strange time in the
cosmos today everything we experience is
governed by certain immutable laws of
nature which are ultimately controlled
by the interaction of four major forces
the strong force holding atoms together
the weak Force governing certain types
of radioactivity the electromagnetic
force Distributing energy over great
distances and gravity as Max Planck
predicted at the end of the 19th century
the strong weak and electromagnetic
forces can be quantized represented and
thought of as Tiny individual Parcels of
interaction similar to particles of
matter these so-called messenger
particles are known respectively as
gluons w and z bosons and photons
but gravity is different
with his general theory of relativity
Albert Einstein was responsible for
overthrowing the classical mechanical
definition of gravity instead he
conceptualized it as the curvature of
space-time a warping in the very fabric
of reality through various large-scale
experiments general relativity has been
verified time and time again and the
gravity-induced curvature of space-time
is now recognized as a property inherent
to the universe which affects all matter
and energy within it therefore during
the Planck era long before any of the
conventional laws of nature Hells sway
it was gravity that was the first to
manifest but there is a problem
everything we know about the workings of
gravity today is based on Einstein's
successful Theory but that theory is
only really tested and verified on
larger scales during the Planck era
however her entire observable universe
was condensed into an area many trillion
times smaller than a proton and so
general relativity doesn't really help
instead the Dynamics of the extremely
tiny are governed by quantum mechanics
at Scales small enough that we can
consider the individual subatomic
particles of matter or the quantized
messenger particles of force and energy
and entirely different set of rules hold
sway where nothing is ever where you
expect it to be and the Very Act of
observing changes the outcome instead of
dealing in absolutes Quantum physicists
consider probabilities and nothing ever
stays the same for long
fortunately for us this Lawless Quantum
world only Reigns on nanoscopic scales
and by the time we reach magnitudes that
we're more familiar with the
probabilistic weirdness averages out but
during the universally nanoscopic Planck
error there is no escaping the quantum
and herein lies the problem for
understanding how things actually worked
in that moment general relativity and
quantum mechanics are fundamentally
incompatible with one another so
researchers are still searching for a
solution a so-called quantum gravity
that is able to reconcile two of the
most important theories in modern
physics and properly describe how the
Planck error Universe behaved
unfortunately it is a question that
cannot reasonably be tackled by
experimental means considering the vast
energies needed to produce and study the
other Force messenger particles inside
collider facilities and the elevated
plane that gravity occupies in defining
all of space-time it would take a
particle accelerator roughly the
diameter of our entire solar system to
generate enough power to truly probe
gravity during the extremes of the
Planck era
but this doesn't stand in the way of
theoretical speculation and
extrapolation
one idea suggests that like the other
fundamental forces of nature gravity
also is communicated by a messenger
particle a Quantum unit of gravity that
has come to be known as a graviton but
gravity as a force is so much weaker
than the others than its meager
messenger would be practically
impossible to detect another theory
known as a loop quantum gravity is very
different in this physicists imagine the
smooth and ever-changing geometry of
space-time to be ultimately pixelated on
the very smallest scales and by
rewriting Einstein's equations of
general relativity in terms of lines or
Loops instead of points the calculations
for gravity on a Quantum scale become
much more manageable
and perhaps the leading possible quantum
gravity solution continues to rumble
away in the background of theoretical
physics
String Theory imagines the point-like
particles of traditional physics as
one-dimensional vibrating strings and it
is the vibrational state of the strings
that defines what a particle is as well
as the elusive force of gravity and yet
in order to make the mathematics of
string theory work it becomes necessary
to involve no fewer than 10 or 11
Dimensions many of which would be folded
in on themselves or partitioned into two
or five-dimensional structures known as
brains the fundamental objects of an
even more elusive overarching Theory
with the simple moniker m
and so each of these hypotheses for how
quantum gravity may actually work is
more mind-bending than the last rooted
in the abstractions of mathematics and
almost impossible to visualize
and yet that is what we are trying to do
when we cast our minds back to imagine
the first fraction of a second of our
universe during the Planck error
ironically it was in the 1950s when the
science of quantum mechanics was still
in its infancy that American theoretical
physicist John Archibald wheeler
provided us with a tangible description
of conditions in that turbulent and
confusing time he imagined the early
Universe to be composed of a bubbling a
dynamic quantum foam
this quantum foam as wheeler described
it comes about because of the dynamical
and unpredictable nature of interactions
on the quantum scale Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle seriously
compromises our ability to Define length
time or energy at any one point within
the planck-sized universe and so the
continuous and coherent space-time that
we are familiar with today is replaced
by an inherently unpredictable and
varying foam-like texture that shifts
and changes randomly Quantum micro black
holes and wormholes spring spontaneously
into existence and then disappear
Without a Trace without any apparent
cause and effect in this highly
energetic super Compact and miniaturized
Cosmos for the briefest of moments
Anything Goes
but after only 100 million trillion
trillion trillionths of a second the
widespread unpredictability of the
Planck error comes to an end as the
minuscule growth and cooling of the
universe Heralds a new epoch
the universe won't look or behave
anything like it does today for a while
but from here on out our current
theories do at least stand a chance of
describing just what is going on
[Music]
everything in our universe is controlled
and defined by the four fundamental
forces of nature
imagine turning on your television
gravity keeps you pinned firmly to the
seat of your chair holds the Earth's
atmosphere close to the surface and
holds the Earth in orbit around our
nearest star providing a habitable
environment for your continued existence
yet despite this gravity is relatively
weak and you can overcome it with the
muscles of a single arm to lift the
remote
in response to your button press
invisible infrared light electromagnetic
radiation beams across the living room
from the front of the remote the picture
comes to life in front of you through
millions of tiny pixels emitting visible
light another form of electromagnetic
radiation which travels back across the
room and into your eyes your eyeballs
themselves are marvels of evolutionary
Innovation but they ultimately rely on
the properties and behaviors of the
atoms within electrons and nuclei held
together by the electromagnetic force
the atomic nuclei themselves are held
together by the strong nuclear force
protons and neutrons Force together in
the center of the atom not only that
these protons and neutrons are really a
combination of three smaller subatomic
particles called quarks which are also
bonded by the same pull every atom in
your body in the television in existence
itself relies upon this Force has your
eyes focus and you engage with the
pictures moving on the screen in front
of you each of the nerves inside your
brain fire at up to 200 times per second
all of that coordinated electrical
potential relies on a proper balance of
potassium in the body like the other
elements potassium is held together by
the strong nuclear force but there is
something else at play as well because
potassium is very slightly radioactive
and around 5000 potassium atoms
radioactively Decay every second a Decay
driven by the weak nuclear force and so
150 million kilometers away the core of
our sun burns with the heat of a stellar
furnace powered by the fusion of
hydrogen into helium this incredibly
powerful reaction is responsible for the
heat that keeps the Earth habitable and
on a galactic scale the very elements
that make up the planet the television
and you
and all of this is also reliant on the
weak nuclear force
each of these four fundamental forces
gravity electromagnetism and the strong
and weak nuclear forces act together to
shape our experience of the universe and
so it has been for the majority of our
cosmos's multi-billion year history but
in the very first moments of time
conditions conspired to craft a very
different set of rules
during the grand unification Epoch which
followed the Planck era there were only
two forces
but how could this be the case
the key to visualizing this lies in a
coin toss flip a coin to decide between
two equally weighted choices heads for
one team tales for the other the
decision is only reached when the coin
settles after the flip when the energy
provided by the flexing of thumb and
forefinger is completely spent and the
disc comes to rest
before that point when the coin is still
imbued with energy and it is spinning
through the air or across the table it
is nion impossible to even distinguish
the two faces the two choices available
to you there is just a single spinning
orb with characteristics all of its own
and this is what we encounter when we
examine the behaviors of the fundamental
forces at higher energies the energies
that were present in the nascent
Universe increase the temperature
dramatically and the individual
properties of the weak nuclear force and
the electromagnetic force begin to
weaken and blur into one another we no
longer see the distinct heads of
electromagnetism and the Tails of the
weak Force but rather the spinning
faceless force of the two United the
so-called electro-week Force increase
that energy even further and the
spinning coin concept again applies to
the strong force and the electro weak
with high enough temperatures these two
blur into a single unified hole a
process known as Grand unification
this ultimate unification of three of
the major fundamental forces gives rise
to what is known as the electro strong
force though this tidy spinning coin
theory of grand unification has yet to
be definitively proven experimentally
even though the energetic collisions
inside particle accelerators can point
us towards the joining of
electromagnetism and the weak force it
would take energies some million million
times greater for the strong force to
lose its identity in the same way
as for with the gravity the fourth
fundamental force is ever accepted into
the unified fold that is a question for
the mysterious and unpredictable Planck
error and yet another problem for
contending theories of quantum gravity
still the grand unification Theory as it
is known is a strong Contender for
explaining the workings of the universe
just after the Planck error for a period
of time some 10 million times longer
than the entire Planck error the
universe expanded and cooled but it is
Testament to just how dense everything
started out that even by the end of this
time the entire observable Cosmos was
still smaller than a single Quark with a
latent energy of that Cosmos compressed
into such a tiny space the temperature
reached 100
000 trillion trillion Kelvin some
trillion times higher than the Large
Hadron Collider has ever managed these
were the conditions for the grand
unification Epoch ruled by the chimeric
electro strong force and the bizarre
interactions that it brought about
the minuscule Cosmos is filled with
particles undergoing an extreme identity
crisis photons transform spontaneously
into matter antimatter pairs creating
quarks and leptons but these nascent
particles are desperately short-lived
decaying rapidly back into photons
scarcely as soon as they've formed
Electro strong messenger bosons only
serve to complicate the picture helping
quarks to transform into lepitons
leptons into quarks matter into
antimatter and vice versa under the
chaotic rule of grand unification it is
a free-for-all of energy and matter of
particles both virtual and real
[Music]
until a trillion trillion trillionth of
a second after it began
the penny drops
temperatures drop to a mere thousand
trillion trillion degrees rendering it
cool enough for the strong force to
break free for two forces to become
three and everything to change once
again
and yet there is a problem with this
picture while these theories May
adequately describe the behavior of
particles within the earliest moments
after the big bang they fall short of
explaining the large-scale cosmos that
would eventually come to exist
indeed When comparing the starting
conditions with the universal end result
the Big Bang appears
to be broken
[Music]
by July 2022 the iconic James Webb Space
Telescope was well established in orbit
around the sun one and a half million
kilometers out in space it was finally
ready to begin its scientific operations
in Earnest but when it focused its 18
golden mirrors into some of the deepest
reaches of the observable universe
scientists were shocked after seeing the
images returned from the Revolutionary
telescope American astrophysicist Alison
Kirkpatrick wrote in the scientific
journal Nature that she found herself
lying awake at three in the morning
wondering if everything she'd ever done
was wrong
and within a month these images and
Kirkpatrick's comments had grown a life
of Their Own
the fixed speed of light means that the
deeper WE peer into space the further
back in time we are looking and the
distances corresponding to just 200
million years after the beginning of
everything the James Webb Space
Telescope had seen
galaxies not only that but these
galaxies were ordered with much more
structure than anyone had thought
possible series of star and Galaxy
formation had no way to explain it and
it was this that Kirkpatrick had been so
concerned about unfortunately soon her
concerns had been extrapolated to cast
out on the Big Bang itself with some
media Outlets claiming that the Next
Generation telescope had disproved the
landmark Theory with its very first
images thankfully those concerns were
misplaced Kirkpatrick had only been
concerned about existing theories on
Galaxy formation not entire Cosmos
creation the inexplicable structuring of
early galaxies meant that there was a
piece missing from our understanding not
that everything we knew was wrong little
more than a storm in a cosmic teacup
and so the Big Bang is safe from that
quarter for now at least but there's a
complete explanation of how our modern
Universe came to be it has been under
far more severe threat for much longer
when we look at the large-scale
structure of the universe as it is today
there are a number of phenomena that
don't quite add up
to begin with the average temperature
even though Stars Burn at several
million degrees Celsius and empty space
Shivers at just a few degrees above
absolute zero the average temperature
that we observe in One Direction is
remarkably similar to any other 2.7
Kelvin everywhere in the universe all 93
billion light years in diameter of it
how if the universe has been gradually
expanding for nearly 14 billion years
then how can two points further than 14
billion light years apart have averaged
out without breaking the speed of light
the fact that we see such thermal
homogeneity now implies that there was
thermal homogeneity back in the
universe's earliest moments a fact that
seems wildly improbable given the nature
of quantum fluctuations in the
compactified early Cosmos
this is known as the homogeneity problem
or the Horizon problem
but there is more Einstein's general
theory of relativity describes how
massive objects create Curves in
space-time which then governs the
movement and evolution of matter within
that space-time Stars galaxies and black
holes leave pinches and pock marks in
the local scale structure of space-time
but when we zoom out to a larger scale
these imperfections even out to leave a
smoother structure which like the
average temperature of the cosmos seems
to vary very little
the Universe on the largest scales seems
flat if the overall density of matter in
the universe is sufficiently great
space-time will be what's known as
positively curved bending back on itself
like the surface of a sphere this means
that eventually the gravity exerted by
all the matter in the universe will be
enough to slow down and eventually
reverse the trend of expansion
collapsing the universe back in on
itself in a so-called big crunch in
contrast if the overall density is much
lower it results in a negative curvature
of space-time bending out in an open
fashion like the surface of a saddle
with this geometry gravity never
overcomes expansion and the cosmos
continues to grow for eternity which of
these overall geometries holds true has
big implications for the future
evolution of our universe and so it has
been the preoccupation of astronomers to
try to measure the overall curvature of
the cosmos we can see and
counter-intuitively it appears to be
completely
flat
just like the Horizon problem the
likelihood of this being the case is
incredibly small tantamount to tossing a
coin and having it land perfectly on its
Edge for obvious reasons this has become
known as the flatness problem
and there is one additional problem that
blights our theories of the cosmos in
the first trillionth of a second there
seem to be no magnetic monopoles at all
all through the universe electrical
charges exist in positive and negative
pairs canceling one another out to
result in a stable neutrally charged
hole in a similar way magnets are found
with both North and South Poles with
magnetic field lines flowing between
them to produce a stable and balanced
hole however while it is possible for
both positive and negative charges to be
found alone like in isolated protons or
electrons respectively no such isolated
poles exist for magnets no matter where
we look in the cosmos we have yet to
find a lone monopole without its
opposite pairing
and so it was on a December night in
1979 while puzzling over the mystery of
the missing monopoles that theoretical
physicist Alan Guth struck on a
remarkable solution
one that not only addressed his own
problem but also tackled The Horizon and
flatness problems as well instead of
expanding gradually over billions of
years to the vastness we see today goose
found a mechanism by which the universe
could have suddenly and almost
instantaneously inflated to many many
times its original size before slowing
down and continuing in a more linear
expansion
this inflationary period the goose
proposed would see the universe double
in size around 90 times in less than a
trillionth of a second resulting in an
exponential expansion that would
fundamentally change the face of the
cosmos
because when exponential expansion is at
play things get very large
very quickly
consider folding a gigantic piece of
paper in half time and time again
starts out one tenth of a millimeter in
thickness then the first fold will
double that to two tenths and the next
brings it to just under half a
millimeter a third fold doubles it again
and now it is about the thickness of a
fingernail so far so unremarkable but by
the time you reach Seven Falls the
single sheet has now reached the
thickness of an entire notebook tenfolds
and it will be as thick as your hand is
wide and the world record for actually
doing this experiment sits at just 12
folds when in 2002 an American
schoolgirl folded a piece of tissue
paper more than 1.2 kilometers in length
into a bundle over half a meter thick
but if it were possible to make and
handle an even bigger sheet further
folds would increase the thickness
astronomically
23 folds will make the paper around one
kilometer thick and thirty folds will be
enough to get you to space Rising 100
kilometers from the surface of the Earth
42 folds will get you to the moon and 51
will make it to the Sun 81 folds will
make the paper as wide as the Andromeda
galaxy at around 141
000 light years across
and 90 folds equivalent to the 90
doublings the goose proposed for the
inflationary period will transform that
single colossal piece of paper to a
folded pile bigger than the entire Virgo
supercluster 130 million light years
across
this incredible inflation is what Alan
Goose proposed for the entire universe
in less than a trillionth of a second
after the confusing turbulence of the
Planck error and the grand unification
error the hot hyperdense Cosmos blew up
to more than an octillion times its
original size it was this if anything
that put the bang in the Big Bang the
universe which one moment had seemed so
hot energetic and full is now left vast
vacuous and cold
[Music]
though it seems drastic it is indeed An
Elegant solution for the three problems
vexing The Big Bang Theory because this
inflation allows us to entertain the
possibility that the immense Universe we
see isn't actually all there is it is
merely a bubble of observable universe
whose size is defined by the speed of
light the amount of time that has passed
and the expansion that has taken place
since the beginning of time
thanks to inflation and subsequent
expansion our observable bubble is some
93 billion light years in diameter but
it is still merely a fraction of the
universe as a whole and it is in this
unseeable extent that the answers to our
problems can be found
The Horizon problem of thermal
homogeneity is only a problem if the
homogeneity we see applies to the entire
universe but inflation allows the
compactor the universe to contain
extreme thermal variations which are
then flung far apart from one another
during exponential expansion our local
patch of observable universe merely
represents one small part of the whole
which was in thermal equilibrium with
itself before inflation happened and may
be wildly different from other parts
that we cannot see similarly the
flatness problem of space-time curvature
is only a puzzling coincidence if the
flatness we see applies to the entire
universe but if we are only seeing a
tiny fraction of the hole then it is
impossible to say whether it does or not
it could be a matter of perspective from
the seashore an ocean Horizon appears
flat but it is only when we fly far
above the surface perceiving more of the
earth that we see it is in fact curved
in reality The Wider Cosmos may be
positively curved negatively curved or a
twisted combination of both but we are
unable to see past our own Cosmic Shore
and finally the absence of magnetic
monopoles is only a problem if we assume
they are missing from the universe as a
whole but if they existed in the early
Universe in the quantity predicted by
our current models then exponential
inflation would have seen them spread
apart from one another until they were
distributed to roughly one per
observable universe and when we are
looking for a singular monopole within a
sphere 93 billion light years across
it's Little Wonder we haven't found it
yet
foreign
is now securely part of our
understanding of the earliest moments of
the universe and cosmologists have spent
the 40 years since Alan Guth revelation
of figuring out the mechanism by which a
universe can so suddenly and so
drastically blow up the timing of this
dramatic phase coincides with the energy
drop and cooling that saw the end of the
grand unification of fundamental forces
and the emergence of the strong nuclear
force it is theorized by some scientists
that the decay of the ex boson messenger
particles that carried the electro
strong force created a strong inflation
field carried by a new messenger called
the inflaton this overwhelming new
inflation energy drove Universal
exponential expansion which saw Quantum
scale irregularities almost instantly
scaled up to large-scale structure
transient Quantum fluctuations becoming
huge regions of over density and energy
that would provide the seeds for
Galactic clusters and superclusters in
the modern universe
all of this expansion inevitably cooled
and emptied the cosmos leading to a 100
000 fold drop in average energy levels
scientists are as yet unsure of why
exactly inflation stopped but when it
did the inflaton field and particle
decade away pouring much of that energy
back into the universe in a phase known
as reheating and it's this that allows
for the decisive creation of matter
and now in a larger and roomier Cosmos
the laws of nature are approaching
something that we can finally understand
and model this is called the electro
weak Epoch and it lasts until about a
trillionth of a second after the big
bang There are corks and leptons Mata
and antimatter all ruled by gravity the
strong nuclear force and the chimeric
electro weak Force but temperatures and
energies are still far too high for the
strong force to have any real effect on
the supercharged particles in this
post-inflationary Maelstrom similarly
the electro weak Force has little hold
on the matter energy interactions and
while gravity may have pervaded the
universe since its beginning there is
one major component still missing which
renders it all but powerless
until these newly formed particles are
granted Mass they remain unruly and
ungoverned it will take another energy
drop and another cosmological
transformation before we reach a
universe we begin to recognize as our
own
symmetry is everywhere anywhere we look
in nature we find balance regularity and
geometric Harmony but in our own bodies
or the bodies of all animals Great and
Small we are bilaterally symmetric
mirrored down the center and perceive
the greatest beauty in those whose
symmetry is the most perfect many
creatures share our bilateral symmetry
too from the greatest whale to the
lowliest worm and if not mirrored
twofold other animals like starfish and
sea urchins favor five spokes of radial
symmetry scientists have found that
Evolution has a clear preference for
these balanced symmetric forms not least
because they can be constructed from
much more simplistic instructions than
other more complex and non-repeating
geometries and it is mathematical
algorithmic Simplicity that underlies
the symmetries found throughout the
natural non-living World in science
symmetry has a much wider meaning than
its day-to-day use it indicates that
something is the same something that
does not change whatever happens from
the laws of physics to the conservation
of energy and momentum the universe is
inherently symmetrical positive charges
are balanced with negative ones some
particles spin clockwise others spin
counterclockwise and if you measure the
strength of gravity on Alpha Centauri
you will get the same result as in our
own solar system and yet the universe is
not perfectly symmetrical just like the
human body when examined more closely as
the heart shifted to one side there are
also flaws in the perfect balance of the
cosmos there are some particles that
never spin clockwise and others that
never spin counterclockwise there is an
imbalance in the amount of matter and
antimatter there are things that
electric Fields can do that magnetic
fields cannot despite the two being
notionally equivalent and many of these
imbalances are key to the functioning of
reality
but it did not start this way
indeed for the first trillionth of a
second or so cosmologists believe that
everything was perfectly symmetric there
was balance
but that all changed with the final
separation of the forces and the
emergence of something that would come
to influence much of existence
Mass
just as dropping temperatures Herald
phased changes in water from Vapor to
liquid to solid ice fundamentally
changing its properties at each
transition and reducing its symmetry so
the dropping temperatures in the young
Cosmos brought about phase changes in
the energy and matter that filled it as
the four fundamental forces finally
fully split and crystallized as separate
entities a new era dawned the Quark
error defined for the first time by the
interactions of matter
the biggest single object yet discovered
in our universe is probably the
hypergiant star uy scooty
with a diameter some 1700 times larger
than our sun if it sat at the center of
our solar system its Outer Edge would
sit just beyond the orbit of Jupiter and
yet it like all stars is composed almost
entirely of some of the smallest things
to be found in the universe individual
atoms of the lightweight elements
hydrogen and helium hydrogen is the
smallest of the atoms which themselves
were once considered the smallest thing
possible their very name derives from
the Greek word for unsplittable but we
now know thanks to Revolutions in atomic
theory throughout the early 20th century
that atoms are eminent splitable a fact
which is given rise to some of the most
devastating weapons in human history
hydrogen and helium for all their
Simplicity are composite particles of
protons neutrons and electrons which can
be isolated and manipulated with
relative ease but even these are not the
smallest fundamental particles there are
protons and neutrons are themselves
Composites of even smaller units called
quarks whose various properties
alongside those of electrons ultimately
govern the characteristics and behavior
of everything including
uy scooty
the search for the fundamental particles
of matter has been a guiding quest for
physicists for some 200 years
experiments to crack open smaller and
smaller particles to reveal what lies
inside require vast amounts of energy
which can only be obtained by
accelerating those particles to blinding
speeds and then smashing them into one
another in particle colliders examining
the wreckage of such collisions we can
piece together a full picture of the
building blocks of our universe this
picture which has come to be known as
the standard model of particle physics
is theoretically all we need to explain
why everything looks the way it does in
the cosmos today normal matter as we
have seen is composed of protons and
neutrons which are collectively known as
hadrons but they are themselves composed
of a combination of quarks each with
distinct characteristics such as mass
charge spin as well as another property
called color an arbitrary name which has
no relation to color but helps to
explain how they bind together in groups
a positively charged proton is made from
two up quarks and one down Quark while
an uncharged Neutron is two downs and an
up but there are other flavors of Quark
out there with esoteric names like
strange charm top and bottom which
combine to form more exotic composite
hadron particles which are scarcely ever
seen outside of physics experiments
and so despite smashing hadrons together
in these experiments with ever
increasing Force physicists have found
no hint that quarks are made of anything
smaller they truly seem to be the bottom
of the rabbit hole meanwhile the
electrons that orbit Atomic nuclei
appear similarly indivisible they are a
kind of particle known as a lepton and
while all normal matter makes do with
the negatively charged electron there
are exotic varieties to be found inside
alkylos muons Tau lepitons and several
varieties of neutrino can all be found
in the wreckage of particle collision
and so our standard model consists of 12
fundamental unsplittable particles of
matter six types of quark and six types
of lepiton in addition to antimatter
counterparts of each of these and the
messenger particles of the fundamental
forces photons for the electromagnetic
force gluons for the strong nuclear
force and w and z bosons for the weak
nuclear force if a virtual particle
exists to communicate gravity through
space-time then it still evades
detection so for now only four Gage
bosons joined the particles of matter to
describe everything within the universe
today
[Music]
at least almost everything
there is one crucial missing piece to
our model so far
and that is Mass
every element in the universe from
hydrogen to plutonium has its own
characteristic Mass corresponding mainly
to the number of protons and neutrons
within its nucleus so it follows that
the majority of an atom's mass comes
from those protons and to neutrons but
when we peer down smaller and smaller to
find the ultimate source of that mass
that is not what we see for it turns out
that a proton weighs in at considerably
more than the sum of its parts the
fundamental particles at the heart of a
proton are the three quarks but the
masses of these amount to just nine
percent of the protons overall Mass the
rest comes from energy stored up inside
that nucleus from the intrinsic
relationship between energy and mass
that Einstein identified with his famed
E equals MC squared equation and from
the bizarre Quantum interactions of
gluons the mediators of the strong
nuclear Force so when we reconsider the
masses of every piece of normal matter
in the universe more than 90 percent of
it doesn't actually come from the stuff
of matter at all but from the latent
energy and empty space within but quarks
do still have mass something separate
something different to this energy and
the reason for this was a mystery for a
long time photons and gluons get by just
fine without mass at all electrons and
neutrinos have even less than the
smallest Quark while the W boson carrier
of the weak Force weighs in at some
forty thousand times heavier than an up
Quark heavier even than an entire iron
atom so what causes this incredible
disparity in Mass
why to particles have mass at all
this was the question that plagued
British theoretical physicist Peter
Higgs in the 1960s while teaching and
researching at the University of
Edinburgh as a solution to the problem
he suggested that all particles first
came to existence in the universe
without any mass at all and that at some
point within the first Split Second a
new kind of energy field emerged and
permeated all of space-time giving the
various particles the property of mass
this Higgs field as it became known
would be communicated by its own
quantized messenger particle the Higgs
boson which would sit alongside the
other 16 particles of the standard model
and play a major role in describing the
behaviors and interactions of matter in
the universe and yet even though Higgs
theory was sound it would take nearly 50
years to finally find The elusive Higgs
boson in the meantime in order to
bolster support for this expensive and
seemingly esoteric search the UK
Minister for science promised in 1993 to
buy a bottle of champagne for the best
analogy to explain the actions and
importance of the Higgs field to the
general public despite various
suggestions featuring pools of syrup
prisms and electric Fields it was
physicist David Miller from University
College London who ultimately claimed
the prize with the description that
focused on a busy cocktail party
[Music]
at this party he said everyone is
happily chatting among themselves and a
normal person is able to move through
the room with relative ease but when a
more popular figure enters the room they
attract attention from the party goers
everyone wants to talk to them and their
progress through the room is slowed in
this way the room full of partygoers
represents the Higgs field and the
popular figure is a particle that has
been imbued with mass for those too far
away to see the influential person a
rumor passes around the room as people
come together to discuss their arrival
this physical Rippling through the crowd
can be thought of as the messenger Higgs
boson
while the analogy isn't perfect it has
stood the test of time and time was what
was needed in what ultimately proved to
be a frustrating search for something
akin to a needle in a haystack two of
the most powerful particle accelerators
the tevatron had Fermi lab in America
had the Large Hadron Collider at CERN in
Europe smashed particles and searched
wreckage for years the problem was
although Peter Higgs had theorized the
field and boson existed his theories
said nothing about what energies would
be needed to manifest them all the
properties of the particles once they
were found so like searching for a
needle in a haystack when you had no
idea what a needle even looked like
eventually though in 2012 experiments at
the Large Hadron Collider achieved this
seemingly impossible feat scientists
confirmed they had in fact found the
Higgs boson and in doing so proved the
existence and action of the Higgs field
once and for all the particle had earned
its place in the standard model and the
field its role in the evolution of the
early universe
a trillionth of a second after the big
bang the electro weak Force splits
catastrophically in two ending the
perfect symmetry of the universe as the
W and B bosons that carried Decay into
the photons of the electromagnetic force
and the w and z bosons of the weak
nuclear force but this is only the
beginning of the Symmetry breaking the
emergence of the Higgs field around this
time imbues the real and virtual
particles that were created
spontaneously during inflation and
Electro weak splitting with mass the wnz
bosons become heavyweights the quarks
and leptons get their masses according
to their flavor and type or the photon
and gluon continue as massless and
unbounded by the Higgs as they did
before
as the Quark error becomes fully
realized by a billionth of a second
after the big bang the universe is
finally filled with all of the
ingredients the characteristic particles
and the characteristic forces needed to
make stars planets and us
Quark glue on plasma that permeates the
inflated Cosmos is the primordial soup
from which all structures in the
universe will be made
our universe is full of incredible
variety and diversity there are stars
that burn hot and fast exploding
catastrophically after scarcely a
million years and others that Sizzle
away slowly unchanging for trillions of
years there are multitudes of planets
Giant Gas worlds scorched and Barren
Rocky worlds and occasionally green
watery life-ready worlds and on those
worlds that do host life like Earth
there is every kind of life form you can
imagine from Tiny bacteria who breathe
sulfur or methane to self-aware and
cognizant Apes that build structures and
telescopes
in the potentially infinite extent of
the cosmos There is almost infinite
scope for variety but there are also
certain facets of reality that are
immutable and constant regardless of
where you are in the cosmos or How You
observe them
these so-called constants of nature have
been revealed one by one as scientists
expand our understanding of how the
universe behaves time and time again we
stumble across seemingly magical numbers
unrelated to any other physical law or
phenomenon like the speed of light
through a vacuum often considered the
absolute speed limit for anything
traveling through the universe it is
2.99792 times 10 to the 8 meters per
second or the universal constant of
gravitation which describes how strongly
two objects will be attracted to one
another due to gravity it is
6.67384 times 10 to the minus 11 meters
per second squared per kilogram and the
list goes on there are precise and
definable constraints relating the
energy of particles to their temperature
for the strength of magnetic fields
produced by electric currents and for
the strength of an electric field that
forms in response to electric charges
less obvious seriously but still
importantly the masses of the
fundamental particles are also set at
constant but seemingly arbitrary amounts
affect that even the Higgs mechanism is
unable to account for and so why should
these natural relationships have these
precise values
it is a problem that vexed even the
great physicist Richard Feynman when he
considered what is known as the fine
structure constant that essentially
describes the strength of
electromagnetic forces between particles
defining the chances that an electron
will absorb a photon its value is a
little over 137 but there is no link
between it and any other physical law no
reason for it not to be 12 or 135 or
3015 the fact that it is 137 rather than
any other number is crucially important
for the overall state of the universe if
it were much larger or smaller then it
would seriously affect the stability of
protons throughout the cosmos meaning
that matter would have a hard time
staying together and the same goes for
most of the other natural constants if
gravitation were weaker than it is the
universe would be filled with just an
ever-thinning soup of hydrogen gas if it
was stronger then all matter would be
drawn into black holes or violent
short-lived Stars leaving no room for
planets and Life to form the many
constants of nature may seem arbitrary
but they are also finely tuned to allow
for the varied and diverse Universe we
find ourselves Within
[Music]
but why we still don't know
is it just a lucky coincidence or the
Hallmark of a creator with their hands
on the dials or as many scientists
suppose is it that our universe is
merely one of a multitude all created
with different starting conditions and
different values for those fundamental
constants the vast majority having
resulted in failed Barren universes and
only those in which the values are just
right able to culture cosmological
variety longevity and consequently
us
whatever the reason this fine tuning is
already hugely important in the opening
seconds of existence
by the time a billionth of a second has
passed since the Big Bang the universe
has been filled with an astonishing
abundance of quarks leptons and virtual
particles but temperatures and energies
were still too high for any of these
fundamental particles to interact
meaningfully with one another
temperatures drop and by a millionth of
a second after the big bang the universe
is a mere one trillion degrees Celsius
gluons and quarks finally slow down
their frantic vibration allowing them to
interact with one another for the very
first time as we have seen protons and
neutrons are composite particles each
made from three quarks but the component
parts of a proton two up Corks And A
Down Quark are not natural bedfellows
the op quarks both have positive charge
and like charges repel the closer the
like charges get the more strongly they
reject one another so it takes the
assembled might of the strongest force
of all the strong nuclear force mediated
by gluons to hold them together into a
stable hadron particle but it turns out
the internal anatomy of a proton is even
stranger than we might imagine not only
is the majority of the mass made up of
energy and Quantum Dynamics but the
composition of the matter isn't as
constant as we might imagine
sometimes one of the typical quarks
inside a proton can spontaneously
shapeshift into a charm quark and its
antimatter counterpart the
transformation is extremely short-lived
however and the charm corks quickly
recombine but it means that protons are
ultimately a constantly changing blur of
the normal quarks known as valence
quarks as well as gluons and charm
quarks since both the gluons and the
transient charms can be considered
virtual particles that means that the
vast majority of a proton as much as 99
percent is actually made up of particles
that don't really exist
the internal workings of protons and
neutrons may be truly bizarre but in the
first millionth of a second of the
universe they are becoming an Ever more
prominent part of the universe's makeup
however thanks to the effect of the weak
force in this hot dense plasma newly
formed protons can easily change
identity to become neutrons and vice
versa it's only as the temperature drops
even further as the universe is
approaching one second old that this
particular Quirk of the weak Force
becomes ineffective and the protons and
neutrons eventually slow their switching
during this so-called freeze out the
hadron's choose an identity once and for
all
foreign
and it is when this happens that the
seemingly arbitrary fine-tuned constants
of nature in this case the masses of the
up and down quarks have their first real
opportunity to shape the future of our
Cosmos
because down quarks are heavier than
their up cousins and neutrons contain
two downs the mass of a neutron is very
slightly greater than the two upper
containing proton so was the final
identity switches take place in an
ever-cooling Cosmos the downhill energy
slope from heavy Neutron to lighter
proton is favored over the
energy-intensive hall in the opposite
direction it is this very slight Mass
difference that ultimately results in an
imbalance in the number of protons to
neutrons in the universe from that point
on with roughly seven protons to every
Neutron and this it transpires has been
an important ratio for the formation of
the universe as we know it
protons are the basis for hydrogen and
helium the fuel for stars and the
building blocks for all other heavier
elements in the universe the abundance
of these charged particles over the
uncharged neutrons is what allows for
Elemental interactions leading to
chemistry and biology if things had
started out differently if the downcore
had been allocated a slightly lower Mass
during the fine-tuning of our reality
than the universe we see today would be
very different if neutrons weighed less
than protons then it would have been
those that were favored during freeze
out with more uncharged neutrons than
protons there is a limit to what
chemistry could reasonably be
accomplished hydrogen consisting of only
a proton with no neutrons in attendance
wouldn't be stable for long periods of
time some of the heavier protons could
have been saved by binding to neutrons
before decaying away creating atoms of
helium but helium is often considered
the most inert of all the elements it is
inherently stable but unwilling to react
between this and the overabundance of
generally unreactive neutrons it would
be hard to imagine how nuclear fusion
could work we would be left with a cold
Dark Universe with no stars no galaxies
no planets and certainly now us
foreign
[Music]
we can therefore be thankful for the
universe's inexplicable leaning towards
protons over neutrons but this isn't the
only imbalance that becomes baked into
the cosmos around this point in its
Evolution there is also a mysterious but
fortuitous lack of antimatter
one day in the future as WE peer into
the sky we may be looking in the right
corner at the right time to see an alien
civilization
destroy itself
scarcely more dramatic than the subtle
brightening of one of the faintest stars
in the black but representing an
energetic explosion from a weapon
powerful enough to level an entire world
history tells us that disagreement and
Discord is a common theme among Earth
civilizations and there's no reason to
believe this wouldn't be the case
elsewhere in the galaxy and so on a
warring alien world as on Earth efforts
to Prevail over the enemy lead to an
arms race from sharpened points to
explosive projectiles Nano Machinery to
atomic bombs the struggle for the most
destructive Weaponry goes on
these Advanced extraterrestrials are
still not satisfied and soon turn their
attention to an even more powerful
source of latent energy with greater
technological prowess than Humanity they
have learned to produce and isolate
particles of antimatter holding them in
a vacuum suspended by electromagnetic
forces until it is time for them to be
deployed but they do not need vast
quantities of fuel or any sort of
trigger for the moment that antimatter
comes into contact with the normal
matter that prevails on their home world
the particles will annihilate together
destroying themselves and releasing vast
amounts of energy just one gram of
antimatter releases as much energy as a
traditional nuclear weapon with some 90
kilograms of fuel and as the arms race
goes on the stockpiles grow whether it
is used in Anger confusion or simply by
accident the detonation of this
antimatter Weaponry occurs Knight turns
to day in
scorching winds raise entire cities
destroying both warring factions and all
other life on the planet the entire
world is transformed for centuries
to come
such is the devastating possibility of
antimatter coming into contact with
matter
and yet we are surrounded by it every
day
it was the English physicist Paul De Rak
who in 1928 first predicted the
existence of antimatter
working to integrate Einstein's theory
of special relativity with the
relatively new science of quantum
mechanics he realized his equations
applied not only to negatively charged
electrons but also to positively charged
equivalence thereby predicting a
particle that was entirely new to
science an anti-electron or positron
four years later an independent American
physicist Carl Anderson actually
detected this elusive particle in a
rudimentary instrument called a cloud
chamber with the existence of antimatter
now proven physicists turned their
attention to other antimatter particles
in the 1950s the bevatron accelerator in
California succeeded in detecting the
first anti-proton and the first
anti-neutron and in 1995 scientists
finally assembled an anti-hydrogen atom
now we recognize antimatter in a wide
variety of settings from supernovae and
black hole Jets to the radioactive decay
of potassium in a banana producing a
positron roughly every 75 minutes
so antimatter may not be confined to
futuristic sci-fi settings but it is
still hugely outweighed by normal matter
in the universe
based on the notable absence of
annihilation signatures physicists
believe that there can be no more than
one antimatter particle for every
quadrillion matter particles within the
Milky Way and this is just as well
because if there were equal quantities
of both then Annihilation would have
resulted in the ultimate destruction of
all particles leaving nothing with which
to build stars and planets
but the question of how this lucky
imbalance came about is one that still
troubles physicists could it be another
Quirk of fine-tuning
in the beginning antimatter would have
been formed in tandem with Mata with
pairs of particles forming from
spontaneous energy transformations
within the universe's first billionth of
a second but in such a dense environment
they wouldn't have lasted long before
encountering their opposite annihilating
together and transforming back into
energy this process of spontaneous
creation and destruction continues until
the temperature of the universe drops
and no new Quark anti-cork or lepton
anti-lepton pairs are made but gluons
are not Discerning on what kinds of
matter they assemble and as protons and
neutrons are being made for the first
time they are accompanied by an equal
number of antiprotons and anti-neutrons
everything should be in balance at this
point there should be no difference in
the quantity of matter and antimatter
and since the two kinds of particles
behave identically and are only
destroyed in pairs as well they should
continue to be equal amounts of each
but this isn't what we see
at some point between a millionth of a
second and two minutes into the
universe's timeline the balance of
antimatter and matter changes until only
one antimatter particle in a billion
remains and to this day physicists still
aren't certain why
it could be partly as a result of the
broken symmetry that came about with the
emergence of the weak Force experiments
by Chen Chang Wu in the 1950s showed
that quarks and anti-quarks are in fact
treated slightly differently by the laws
of nature the difference is very small
but it is significant enough for us to
see even so scientists don't think it is
enough to explain the overwhelming
Triumph of matter over antimatter in the
early Universe instead they entertain
the possibility that another as yet
undetected and potentially extinct
particle has a role to play the idea
comes from another kind of asymmetry
that has been found within the standard
model every particle and anti-particle
we have found exists in both
right-handed and left-handed forms
representing a kind of symmetry in
handedness that physicists call parity
but there is an exception where parity
symmetry appears to be broken
experimental physicists have only been
able to find left handed neutrinos
whereas all the anti-neutrinos are
right-handed and so where are the
right-handed neutrinos and left-handed
anti-neutrinos
scientists speculate that they may have
existed early on within the universe's
first millionth of a second but were
unstable and decayed away if they
decayed preferentially into matter
rather than antimatter then this could
have laid the foundation for mata's
ultimate Triumph
the theory is a tantalizing one but
unfortunately there is not much that can
be done to prove it until we know more
about these mysterious missing neutrinos
and it won't be until the universe is
one second old the neutrinos will have
anything to tell us at all
when we peer into the deepest reaches of
the night sky we are greeted with
wonders in almost every wavelength there
are delicately curled galaxies colorful
nebulae and piercing Points of Light
known as quasars far distant
supermassive black holes swallowing
matter and light at the centers of
galaxies
but these quasars also illuminate
another curious feature that permeates
deep space known as the Lyman Alpha
Forest
the constant speed of light through the
expanding vacuum of space means that the
more distant an object is the older it
is as well so when we see quasars at
Great distances we are seeing them as
they appeared billions of years ago and
the light they emit is redshifted
stretched into the red parts of the
electromagnetic spectrum compared to how
they would normally appear
but when we examine the spectral
signatures of such distant and ancient
quasars there is more to see than just
the red-shifted light they give off at
shorter wavelengths there are also sharp
dips in the light we see and sometimes
so many that they cluster thickly like a
dense Thicket of Tall Pine trees on an
Alpine mountain side this is the Lyman
Alpha forest and it's created not by
trees but by low density clouds of
hydrogen gas lurking in Intergalactic
space because when light passes through
a cloud of hydrogen some of it is
absorbed leading to a dip in the
spectrum that we eventually intercept
here on Earth and this is what is
happening with the light from distant
ancient quasars with every dip in the
Spectrum corresponding to an otherwise
invisible hydrogen cloud
visualizing these tenuous structures is
remarkable enough in itself but there is
more we can tell from the structure of
this spectral Forest
astronomers have noticed that the
absorption dips cluster most thickly at
high red shifts which correspond to
Great age giving us an insight into the
chemistry and composition of the
earliest Universe compared to today
early space was full of these low
density hydrogen clouds such that it
became impossible for the quasar's light
to avoid them and it was that hydrogen
that became the nursery for stars and
galaxies and was itself seeded in the
first moments of the universe's
existence
by the time a single second has passed
in the history of the universe a great
deal has happened it is now a mere 10
billion degrees Celsius it is filled
with the victors of Ruthless particulate
battles along with the energetic Photon
shrapnel of countless mutually
destructive encounters through quirks in
the properties of the remaining
particles the balance between protons
and neutrons is set as the era of
spontaneous particle births and swaps is
finally brought to a close those
particles that possess mass today are
already endowed with it thanks to the
Higgs field and the four forces that
rule our lives today the strong nuclear
force electromagnetism the weak nuclear
force and gravity are now in full and
comprehensible operation
so far the workings of the one second
old Universe has Lane primarily within
the realm of theoretical physics with
our most powerful instruments still
struggling to generate the kinds of
energies that prevailed within those
first moments but we are now entering an
era of the universe that can be studied
more meaningfully by experimental
physicists and even astronomers we are
finally reaching a part of our
cosmological history that we can hope to
observe
even
map
in the icy wastes of Antarctica for a
couple of weeks a year the sun does not
set
and this is where the work started
spraying hot water directly downwards
into the ice in January 2005 scientists
working on The Cutting Edge Ice Cube
neutrino Observatory began the arduous
58-hour long process of creating the
first 2.5 kilometer hole needed the
first of 80. now the Ice Cube arrays
various holes occupy a square kilometer
of Antarctic ice but this immense size
and improbable location aren't the only
surprising features of this next
Generation telescope for instead of
pointing up into the night sky it stares
down into and through the bowels of the
earth it has no lenses mirrors or radio
dishes but instead is made up of over 4
000 modules dangled on over 80 strings
deep in holes in the ice hanging like
pearls in the cold dark Antarctic depths
as counterproductive as this may sound
it is in fact the ideal kind of
construction for observing one of the
most elusive particles in the entire
universe and the Ice Cube neutrino
Observatory is joined by similar
projects at the bottom of gold mines
deep beneath the world's largest lake
and in the hearts of Japanese mountains
all dedicated to the search for the
mysterious
neutrino
as a particle the neutrino was first
proposed in the 1930s when particle
physicists were balancing the equations
of nuclear Decay observing how a neutron
would sometimes spontaneously Decay into
a proton and an electron Wolfgang Pally
noticed that a tiny amount of energy was
missing which he hypothesized was
another kind of particle to small
lightweight and ghostly for us to have
any hope of detecting it indeed with the
frequency of this kind of nuclear Decay
100 trillion of these ghostly particles
must be streaming through our bodies
every second without us having any
notion of their passage but scientists
do not accept defeat that easily and in
1951 a pair of American physicists Clyde
Cohen and Frederick Reigns began to
search for this ghostly particle and in
what became known as project Poltergeist
they turned to powerful nuclear fission
reactions to provide the vast quantities
of energy needed to detect neutrinos
Cohen and Reigns first proposed
detonating a 20 kiloton nuclear payload
and installing an immense detector just
50 meters away from the blast this
detector nicknamed El monstro was
designed to pick up a flash of light
after a neutrino collision and if it had
been built would have been almost a
thousand times larger than any previous
detector in the end however this
experiment proved too challenging and
the scientists turned to the somewhat
more controlled energy release to be
found in nuclear reactors and so in 1956
Cohen and Reigns experiment succeeded
finally achieving the seemingly
impossible detecting the ghost particle
that had been haunting physics for more
than 20 years
these days the detection and study of
neutrinos has advanced greatly and
scientists are now able to produce and
study them in powerful particle
accelerators although there is still a
place for monstrous detectors like the
one in Lake Baikal for neutrinos can be
used to answer not only questions about
our universe today but also its very
first moments
neutrinos are produced in such quantity
by such a variety of electromagnetic
sources that scientists are trying to
use them to study some of the most
extreme events in the modern universe
168 000 years ago a star within the
large magellanic cloud
when supernova
the explosion sent Atomic shrapnel
reeling across Intergalactic space at
nearly the speed of light this shrapnel
including the countless neutrinos that
were emitted in the blast struck the
Earth in 1987 and scientists in Japan
considered themselves extremely
fortunate to be able to detect 11 of
these neutrinos
as insubstantial as this may seem the
fact that astronomers could see the
Supernova through this neutrino lens
help to usher in a new era of
multi-messenger astronomy gravitational
waves telescopes tuned to a variety of
electromagnetic frequencies and
neutrinos could all be deployed together
to study and understand the most extreme
and mysterious events in the universe
but not only that neutrinos give us the
opportunity to probe objects that are
too opaque for light to penetrate since
their extreme unwillingness to interact
with any matter at all sees them stream
through everything from nebuli to stars
and even entire planets and this is
because they only interact with two of
the fundamental forces the weak force
and gravity this remarkable penetrative
ability making them powerful Tools in
probing some of the earliest moments of
the universe
after the decisive formation of matter
around one second after the big bang the
sheer density of hot energetic particles
and photons rendered the early Universe
completely opaque for hundreds of
thousands of years our telescopes which
rely on the passage of photons through
empty space cannot probe this opaque
plasma and so to see further back in
time scientists need a different
approach and that's where the neutrino
comes in less than a second after the
big bang neutrinos and anti-neutrinos
were just another part of the hot Cosmic
soup they collided and Scattered
interacting with other matter because
everything in the still dense Universe
was so energetic but around the one
second Mark temperatures in the universe
dropped to 10 billion degrees Celsius
and the particles correspondingly slowed
eventually they were moving slowly
enough for neutrinos to escape and find
a way through the snarl of other
particles they no longer collided with
matter or light and could therefore
Break Free to leave an imprint of their
passage on the universe and so if we
could find that imprint known to
scientists as the cosmic neutrino
background it would represent an image
of the universe at just one second old
extending our astronomical reach Back In
Time by some 380
000 years but if these Relic neutrinos
from the first second of the universe
are out there they are even more elusive
than their high energy counterparts
compared to the 100 billion high energy
neutrinos per cubic centimeter of space
there are thought to be just 300 from
that earliest time to detect them
directly we would need to build our
instruments with some billion times the
current Precision or somehow detect the
effect they had on the cosmos when they
broke free for as the first things to
stream through the otherwise opaque
Cosmos these tiny particles are expected
to have left miniature Sonic booms in
their wake fundamentally altering the
distribution of matter and energy some
parts of space would have become
slightly hotter and some parts slightly
cooler thanks to this disruption and in
the intervening 13.8 billion years space
has expanded magnifying these patches
into larger scale structure in the
universe if we could decode some of that
large-scale structure returned into the
distribution of galaxies today then we
may just be able to tune into the Echoes
of a universe one second old
and this is not the only modern mystery
that could have its origins in the one
second old Cosmos
this is tan 618.
at some 18.2 billion light years away
from us it burns some 140 trillion times
brighter than the sun making it one of
the brightest objects in the known
universe
sought to be nearly 11 billion years old
despite its incredible Luminosity it is
actually one of the cosmos's biggest
black holes
understood to be a hypermassive black
hole at the center of a galaxy whose
trillions of stars it far outshines tons
618 has a mass that is some 66 billion
times that of our sun and is more than
15 000 times more massive than
Sagittarius A star the black hole at the
center of the Milky Way in fact this
single black hole is heavier than all
the stars in the Milky Way put together
Mata is falling into it at speeds of
more than 10 000 kilometers per second
causing intense heating so that the
doomed material in its accretion disk
glows brightly despite the light
swallowing dark heart at its Center
turn 618 may be the largest we have
found but it is by no means the only
such Titan lurking at the hearts of
galaxies
supermassive black holes with masses
more than a hundred thousand times out
of our sun are a common feature of large
galaxies and are thought to be a major
influence on how those Galaxies have
formed and evolved over billions of
years these hot massive Hearts
themselves are thought to grow by
swallowing Stellar Mata from the
galactic Entourage
but there is something about the timing
of these supermassives that doesn't
quite add up when astronomers survey the
sky they find these gigantic black holes
dating to just a few million years after
the big bang despite the fact our models
do not allow for the birth and death of
Enough stars to feed such early Giants
some of the supermassive black holes we
have found grew to a billion times the
mass of our sun by less than a billion
years after Universe formation when
according to models of star formation
only around 100
000 solar masses should have been
possible
[Applause]
a potential solution to this conundrum
may be found in a theory that was
developed many years before we were even
aware of the oversized early
supermassifes in 1971 Stephen Hawking
proposed that there was another way that
black holes could be formed without any
precursor stars at all but rather from
density fluctuations in the very early
Universe he called them primordial black
holes
during the radiation dominated era when
the universe was still an energetic
plasma of photons and matter major
inhomogeneities essentially lumps of
matter would have resulted from the
inflation and subsequent reheating of
quantum irregularities in the nascent
Universe gravity already inherent to the
universe would have acted on these
density contrasts collapsing vast areas
of gas down on itself all over the early
Universe however there was only around a
one second window after the big bang
when this could have happened before the
universe expanded and cooled to such a
size that gravity was no longer
effective at pulling together matter
into these black hole prisons after that
the Universe would have to wait many
millions of years before a new black
hole would form through the death of
stars but these primordial black holes
could be the seeds for the otherwise
unexplainable black holes we are
detecting today the problem is although
this Theory seems consistent with our
understanding of how Mata behaved in the
early Universe we have very little
information on what exactly they did so
and how large they could have grown in
that one second window mathematically
the later a primordial black hole forms
the larger it would be and so estimates
for their size vary spectacularly
ranging from minuscule specs weighing a
hundred thousandth the mass of a
paperclip to mammoths a hundred thousand
times heavier than our sun
and so how do we find and identify them
if they do exist
in the 1970s Stephen Hawking also
theorized that black holes do more than
just swallow matter and grow ever larger
he suggested they could lose some of
their weight through what became known
as Hawking radiation this weight loss is
faster the smaller a black hole is and
The Runaway acceleration of radiation
would ultimately lead to the
obliteration of a black hole in an
explosion equivalent to 1 million
Megaton hydrogen bombs any black hole
that was less than 100 billion kilograms
in Mass could be expected to Decay away
within the age of the universe so
scientists have begun searching for
these characteristic explosive death
throws with instruments like the
space-based Fermi gamma ray telescope
other potential methods for searching
for these elusive primordial seeds
involve looking for micro lensing and
magnification of stars and galaxies as
the black holes pass in front or trying
to detect the destruction of dense Stars
caught in the primordials gravitational
Wells
but all these Studies have accomplished
so far is to rule out certain size
ranges leaving an ever-shrinking
envelope of possibility for how big
primordial black holes can be and when
they formed
although astronomers have not yet given
up hope the next generation of high-tech
telescopes will continue the search with
better reach and precision than ever
before the laser interferometer space
antenna or Lisa will launch next decade
to continue spanning space for
gravitational waves some of which may
come directly from primordial black
holes that have been roaming the
universe since they first formed barely
one second after the beginning of time
on the 5th of December 2022 in the
bowels of the national ignition facility
at Lawrence Livermore National
Laboratory in California Humanity
achieved something remarkable
scientists of the lab focused on 192
lasers inside a one centimeter long gold
cylinder containing a single fuel pellet
to the size of a peppercorn itself
containing two isotopes of hydrogen
deuterium and tritium when the laser
energy struck the walls of the capsule
it heated them up to around 3 million
degrees Celsius a temperature hotter
than the surface of the Sun causing them
to emit x-rays inside the cylinder these
powerful x-rays then blasted the surface
of the pellet and compressed the fuel at
some 400 kilometers per second the fuel
imploded reaching a hundred billion
times atmospheric pressure in less than
10 billionths of a second the atoms of
deuterium and tritium fuse together
transforming them into helium while also
giving off a high energy neutrino and
other energy in total
2.05 megajoules of energy into the
cylinder and 3.15 megajoules were
produced by the fusion reaction in this
way for the first time in nearly 70
years of trying scientists managed to
initiate a productive nuclear fusion
reaction the fusion itself was nothing
new humans have been making deadly
Fusion weapons since the 1950s but this
reaction in 2022 was the first time
we've created Fusion that was able to
release more energy than was put in to
get it started the roughly 50 energy
gain would have been enough to boil
around 20 kettles still the Breakthrough
is a major one for nuclear physics
and yet this is a process that has been
going on naturally in the hearts of
every single star in the universe for
billions of years not only that but the
physics of the universe had this Fusion
figured out within its very first minute
humans have long been preoccupied with
the seemingly magical Act of turning one
thing into another whether it is
producing a bunch of flowers from thin
air or alchemically transmuting base
Metals into valuable gold nothing
fascinates us more than the idea of
getting something novel from something
mundane at the very early Cosmos was
Rife with such Transformations while the
unsettled fundamental forces drove
chaotic identity swaps but such
Transformations continue all around us
even in the modern Universe radioactive
decay mediated by the weak Force sees
Atomic nuclei fracture and a break
transforming elements into their less
massive cousins on regular and
predictable time scales this nuclear
fission occurs in a wide variety of
elements from carbon 14 used for carbon
dating to technetium-99 used for medical
imaging and uranium-235 used as fuel for
nuclear reactors such Radioactive K
occurs as a consequence of unstable
Atomic nuclei and will typically happen
spontaneously under the most ambient
conditions but as the other kind of
nuclear transformation nuclear fusion
sees Atomic nuclei increase their mass
and move up to the periodic table it is
much harder to achieve
[Music]
the identities of all atoms are
determined by the numbers of protons and
neutrons within their nuclei hydrogen
has one proton with different varieties
of isotopes with different masses
possessing different numbers of neutrons
protium has only one proton deuterium
has one additional Neutron doubling the
relative mass of the atom and tritium
has two neutrons bringing the total
relative mass to three only when another
proton is added does the identity of the
element change two protons make a helium
nucleus with helium-3 possessing one
Neutron and the most stable helium-4
having two neutrons the strong nuclear
force is the agent responsible for
binding all of the hadrons together into
stable Atomic nuclei but with protons
sharing a light positive charge they are
pushed apart by another of the four
fundamental forces the electromagnetic
long before the gluons can hold them
together so it takes intense heat and
physical pressure such as that found at
the heart of stars or inside in radiated
golden capsule to push the protons close
enough for the strong nuclear force to
overcome its Force kin and for the
elements to fuse into something new to
make even heavier elements combining
many tens of protons together it takes
even more extreme Cosmic events like
supernovae or mergings of stars despite
their struggles to replicate it in the
lab scientists have a good understanding
of how nuclear fusion Works inside
Stellar furnaces to create new elements
from simple hydrogen and helium they
have even witnessed and understood the
very beginnings of that process inside
so-called failed Stars
Brown dwarfs are massive orbs of gas
larger than the jupiter-like gas giants
but smaller than an active star inside
them there simply isn't enough heat and
pressure for lightweight protium
hydrogen to fuse into helium the process
is accomplished by using heavier
deuterium as an intermediate however
none of these processes help to explain
whether larger atoms of deuterium and
helium came from in the first place
answer for that we need to look back to
an age before Stars before Stellar
Fusion to the universe's very first
minute
when the average temperature of the
universe dropped to around 10 million
degrees Celsius about a microsecond
after the big bang it was finally cool
enough for quarks to bind into protons
and neutrons making the building blocks
for all elements to come but there is a
hundred million year Gulf of time before
we see the first stars begin to shine
powered by the nuclear fusion of atomic
nuclei at their cores so when and how
did these nuclei come together it was in
1948 that the prodigious American PhD
student Ralph Alpha working with his
supervisor George gamoff proposed a
mechanism that would later become known
as Big Bang
nucleosynthesis it was a bold and
inspired Theory but the Brilliance of
Alpha's work was somewhat overshadowed
by gamoth's insistence on including
another author in their seminal paper
who had no part in its development in
his words it seemed unfit to the Greek
alphabet to have the article signed by
Alpha and gamoth only and so the name of
Dr Hans a beta was inserted in preparing
the manuscript for print and so the
alpha beta gamma paper became the
authority on pre-stellar fusion and to
this day provides the foundation for
understanding how the high temperatures
at the beginning of the universe could
turn hydrogen into helium via deuterium
intermediates
[Music]
protium is the lightest variety of
hydrogen consisting of a single proton
so as soon as quarks bound into protons
these hydrogen nuclei existed although
it's important to note that it will be
some time before neutrally charged
hydrogen atoms with both protons and
electrons will form around 10 seconds
after the big bang it was cool enough
for some deuterium nuclei with one
proton and one Neutron to form but in
this hot Cosmic soup temperature and
particle energies were still so high
that the deuterium nuclei were unstable
if they were struck by a photon as was
inevitable under such densities these
first composite nuclei would break apart
again this is known to physicists as the
deuterium bottleneck and until it was
overcome nucleosynthesis simply couldn't
progress past the fusing of one proton
and one Neutron only after another 300
seconds the temperatures drop
sufficiently for deuterium to become
more stable and National elements to
form first deuterium with its one proton
and one Neutron is able to fuse with
individual protons under the intense
compressive force of the entire universe
the result is for the first time an
entirely new stable element helium 3
from this point the next Cosmic creation
is the more common variety of helium
helium-4 composed of two protons and two
neutrons helium-4 nuclei represent the
most stable Atomic nuclei in existence
and are the hardest of all the elements
to break apart because of this and the
conditions that prevailed within those
first few hundred seconds most of the
free protons in the early Universe
become swallowed up into helium and go
no further calculations based on the
initial balance of protons and neutrons
and the available energy at this time
predict that this would result in a
universe that is around 25 percent
helium by mass and this is indeed what
we find even 13.8 billion years after
this energetic burst of helium creation
even after the lives and deaths of
countless Stars the universe is still
around 23 percent helium
this observation alone is a striking
confirmation of Alpha's Theory
and it is here that we see another
example of the fortuitous fine-tuning of
the universe's initial conditions we
already know that if the proton to
Neutron ratio had been different than
much of the universe's ordinary matter
would have decayed away into uncharged
and unreactive neutrons and helium but
similarly even with the proton neutron
ratio we would dealt if the matter in
the cosmos had been any more compact at
the time of big bang nucleosynthesis
then even more helium would have formed
the unreactivity of a universe made
predominantly of helium would have meant
little to no chemistry would have been
possible thereafter again leading to The
Bleak Prospect of a universe with no
stars no galaxies and no us
thankfully however this was not the case
even as so many hadrons settled into
their stable helium nuclei the universe
is still full of latent energy which
could be used for further Fusion
and now the race is on to see how many
novel elements can be created before the
Ambient Energy of the universe drops too
far eventually after around 1200 seconds
of furious Cosmic nucleosynthesis
amounting to little more than 20 minutes
of universal existence the nuclear
furnace finally sputters and dies
it is still blisteringly hot by human
standards but it is simply too cold for
any further nuclei to form and so at
this point only four elements exist
hydrogen helium lithium and beryllium
and because of the short-lived stability
of those beryllium nuclei only the first
three will survive long enough to see
the first stars and to become the
ultimate fuel for creating the other 98
elements that could be found naturally
within the modern universe
at this stage there are 12 hydrogen
nuclei for every helium nucleus and a
billion photons for every composite
matter particle but with these basic
ingredients the stage is truly set for
the formation of everything else
even the deuterium and tritium that
scientists fuse together in California
in 2022 was itself first formed in the
heat of a newborn universe
13.8 billion years ago
life in the universe is a miracle of
chemistry
and as far as we know that chemical
Miracle has only Arisen in one place on
a nondescript wet rocky planet around an
average yellow star sitting on the inner
edge of one of the Milky Ways smaller
spiral arms but how did living things
come to Grace the Earth despite a
healthy fossil record that extends back
through some 3 billion years of the
planet's history this moment of
biological Genesis the spark of Life Is
Lost to The Mists of time biologists
agree that living things are composed of
organic molecules made from carbon
oxygen and hydrogen added to that they
have discovered that all living things
share a common chemical instruction
manual in the form of DNA and RNA which
are themselves composed of repeating
units called nuclear basis cytosine
guanine adenine thymine and uracil
provide a universal language with which
to encode information on how to grow a
leaf a flipper or a hair follicle
but where did these molecules come from
in the first place
some imagine that the warm and potent
chemical environment on the newly formed
Earth provided the perfect conditions
for assembling organic molecules and
nuclear bases from scratch but there is
an alternative theory that the
ingredients for life were not created on
Earth but Among the Stars in the depths
of space
and indeed we are finding compelling
evidence for the stuff of Life far out
in the cosmos
in 1969 American astronomers working out
of the national radio astronomy
observatory in Green Bank West Virginia
detected the characteristic vibration of
formaldehyde molecules containing carbon
hydrogen and oxygen deep in interstellar
space and many other complex molecules
followed scientists have now identified
over 250 organic molecules inside
interstellar clouds and in the shells of
materials surrounding Stars aldehydes
alcohols acids and amines all
fundamental building blocks of the
larger molecules of Life lurking out
there in the lifeless reaches of the
universe foreign
clue to the life-bringing potential of
outer space arrived on Earth as far back
as 1864.
just after 8 pm on the 14th of May a
meteorite fell to Earth in around 20
pieces landing near the town of orgae in
southern France the scientists who
recovered and analyzed the orgy
meteorite reported a composition very
similar to Pete sparking intense debate
over whether this organic matter could
have biological origin but the lack of
any identifiable biological structures
made such a conclusion unlikely though
when the meteorite was reanalyzed almost
a hundred years later using more modern
instruments and techniques chemists were
amazed to discover nuclear-based
molecules of adenine and guanine
identical to those we find in DNA and
RNA today subsequent studies of other
organic Rich meteorites that have fallen
all over the world have found the rest
of Earth life's nuclear bases as well as
several others that aren't found in our
biological makeup a definitive answer to
this question has yet to be revealed but
the observation so far are do at least
point to one certainty a surprising
truth about the cosmos without any
special provocation or encouragement the
universe itself has the capacity to
build molecules and perform remarkable
acts of chemistry
and this space chemistry at its
Beginnings right back in the infant
Universe less than a hundred thousand
years after the beginning of time
the Furious Act of Elemental creation
during Big Bang nucleosynthesis had
ground to a halt after just 20 minutes
of universal existence as the cosmos
expanded and cooled the Ambient Energy
was no longer high enough to fuel
nuclear fusion but conditions were still
extreme the entire Cosmos was still
denser than the air we breathe and
temperatures still too high for
lightweight electrons to slow down
enough to be captured by the newly
formed Elemental nuclei there is also
still more energy than matter in the
universe which exists as a hot
disassociated plasma and it will still
be tens of thousands of years before
further cooling allows anything to begin
to change and yet something is happening
in the chaos
first created in labs in 1925 helium
hydride is an unstable ion of helium
bonded with hydrogen very rarely found
in nature and in 1978 astrochemist John
H black at the University of Minnesota
suggested that it could be found in
abundance
in space
specifically in planetary nebulae which
form from the energetic explosion of red
giant Stars late in their lives he
predicted that a thin layer of ionized
helium would exist around a cloud of
neutral hydrogen in this environment the
helium ions strong need for electrons to
neutralize their charge could drive them
to steal one from the only other source
around the hydrogen the association
between these two in the superheated
nebula would ultimately lead to the
formation of helium hydride ions and yet
the molecule continued to prove elusive
a long search ensued with frustratingly
little success that was until 2019 when
an Innovative telescope managed to
achieve the seemingly impossible
these days most telescopes are either
based on the ground situated high on
mountaintops to avoid the worst of light
pollution weather and Atmospheric
Distortion or they're launched into
space to get rid of those problems
altogether as they orbit the Earth or
the Sun but the Sofia Observatory did
something different it consisted of a
2.7 meter wide mirrored telescope that
was pointed out the back door of a
specially adapted Boeing 747 flying at
over 43 000 feet at this height the
instruments connected to the telescope
could enjoy many of the benefits of a
Space Telescope since they would be
lifted above the majority of the water
in the Earth's atmosphere allowing them
to probe wavelengths of light that water
vapor usually absorbs and critically the
telescope connected to the far infrared
receiver known fittingly by its acronym
great which had sufficient resolution to
finally pick out the faint overlapping
signature of medium hydride ions in deep
space
in the end the detection came from three
days of observation on a planetary
nebula designated NGC
7027 which sits about 3000 light years
away from Earth in the direction of the
cygnus constellation
in this hot and energetic Interstellar
environment just as John black predicted
40 years earlier helium hydride is able
to form and leave its signature on the
nebulous Spectrum detecting this signal
is a Triumph for nearly 100 Years of
experimental and theoretical chemistry
but the implications of its Discovery
here are even greater for the conditions
inside this distant nebula are very
similar to those that prevailed
throughout the holy Universe within its
first few tens of thousands of years
[Music]
Big Bang nucleosynthesis was very
efficient at creating Atomic nuclei but
for hundreds of thousands of years
afterwards Cosmic energies remained too
high for hydrogen deuterium and helium
to combine with electrons to make
uncharged atoms however when ambient
temperatures dropped to around 4000
Kelvin those Wayward nuclei were able to
combine with each other in a specific
order governed by what's known as their
ionization potential and it is because
of this that helium is today considered
the most noble of all the noble gases it
is the most inert and the least likely
to react because of the huge amount of
energy it takes to strip away one of its
electrons and transform it into an ion
but in the early Universe when all that
existed were ions particles with net
charge this supreme grabbing power means
that helium was the first element to
attract electrons and hold on to them
forming the very first uncharged
however this stability for helium was
sadly short-lived it was still too hot
for lone protons to capture electrons to
make hydrogen atoms so the protons
turned to the helium and its balancing
complement of electrons seeking an
arrangement where they could share and
So eventually under the crushing burden
of these clingy protons helium relented
forming the very first chemical bonds
and the first molecule in the universe
creating very unstable helium hydride
ions in the process
despite this instability these
short-lived molecules pave the way for
the creation of other molecules and the
beginnings of space chemistry around 100
000 years having passed since the Big
Bang
today the field of astrochemistry is
well developed as the study of what
molecules we can expect to find in space
and how they form many atomic structures
that are found on Earth are also common
throughout the cosmos including water
and ammonia but others are much more
exotic like dihydron monochloride
cations or hydroperoxyl
though many are yet to be discovered
whatever they turn out to be they
ultimately owe their existence to helium
hydride ions made and unmade in the
first 100
000 years of the universe
[Music]
you may think that you have a good grasp
of the world that surrounds you
with specialized organs dedicated to
sensing light sound the solid Touch of
matter and the chemical nuances of
molecules our brains seem well fitted to
perceive all the possible stimuli the
universe can provide but this simply
isn't true there is much much more to
reality than meets the eye ear or
fingertip
take light most of us are able to see
the world in glorious sharp focused
Technicolor but visible light is just a
tiny fraction of a wider electromagnetic
spectrum whose waves are constantly and
imperceptibly washing over us every
moment of Our Lives high energy gamma
and x-rays are emitted by the food we
eat the bricks that make up our homes
and even our own bodies the radiative
energy from the sun which we may think
we can perceive contains around 10
percent ultraviolet light with the
capacity to penetrate and damage our
skin and eyes and at energies lower than
visible light sunlight is composed of
around 50 infrared radiation some of
which we experience as heat but even on
Lower energies infrared Technologies
like motion sensors and television
remotes send and receive their signals
entirely undetected Bluetooth Wi-Fi
cellular Mobile and GPS all work by
exchanging information through the air
via microwave frequencies of radiation
meanwhile our analog radios and
televisions use the longest wavelength
of em radiation radio waves
if we could see all of them we would be
blinded all told for all our apparent
sentience we are unaware of at least 99
of what is occurring within the universe
perhaps this is just as well as it is
hard to imagine how our brains could
adapt to cope with all the possible
stimuli the relative calm of a night sky
would be a blaze of color and a riot of
sound with sharp points of light and
song from a multitude of sources
and behind it all everywhere a faint
backlit glow the lingering radiation of
the first light
in the cosmos
[Music]
the first few hundred thousand years of
the universe's existence it was utterly
opaque despite being full of light such
a concept is hard for us to imagine
today but since a trillionth of a second
after the big bang the photons that
carried much of the energy in the
universe had become trapped in a maze of
their own making with matter and energy
occupying opposite sides of the same
coin the cooling of the newborn Cosmos
saw Pure Energy transformed into matter
flooding the universe with subatomic
particles the density and intense
vibrational energy of these such that
photons simply could not penetrate the
Swarm it wouldn't be until the ultimate
formation of atoms that anything would
change
in the modern Universe it is uncharged
atoms rather than charged ions that are
the building blocks for everything
around us due to their small size it
takes a staggering number of these atoms
to build anything there are around seven
octillion atoms in each human body
that's a seven followed by 27 zeros
scale this up to the number of humans
and all other living things on earth
factor in the Earth itself and multiply
by all the planets and stars in the
cosmos and the number of atoms in the
entire universe is ungraspable but the
real key to making an atom lies in the
capture of electrons first discovered
towards the end of the 19th century
these negatively charged leptons are 2
000 times lighter than a proton and can
be thought of as a singular point with
no shape or internal structure and such
minute scales quantum physics governs
their behavior and Quantum uncertainty
dictates that we cannot know their speed
and position we would never be able to
pinpoint to single electron instead they
can be thought of as simultaneously
occupying every possible spot that they
can as far as the laws of physics allow
once positively charged Atomic nuclei
have been created during Big Bang
nucleosynthesis the electromagnetic
force helps to ensnare negatively
charged electrons to create a neutrally
charged atom hydrogen nuclei capture a
single electron and helium nuclei
capture two but simple as this may sound
it is not a quick process the
electromagnetic force is some 100 times
weaker than the strong force that holds
hadrons and nuclei together and so the
ambient conditions of the universe must
be that much less energetic if
electromagnetism hopes talasu The
Supercharged electrons and bring them
into the chorale
in the end it takes 380
000 years of cosmic expansion for
temperatures to drop far enough to
around 3000 Kelvin for electrons to
finally Join the Herd and make the first
stable atoms
and when they do the entire universe
transforms
electromagnetic attractions sucks
electrons into stable orbits around
Atomic nuclei where they once roamed
freely through the universe the
electrons are now tightly bound to their
positively charged counterparts opening
up empty space for the first time since
the creation of Mata
the photons that have been trapped in a
labyrinths for hundreds of thousands of
years suddenly find their paths clear
they can escape traveling in straight
lines without instantly striking another
particle they are the first light the
truly penetrates the universe what was
one moment opaque now becomes
transparent what was one moment plasma
now becomes gas and what was one moment
shattered now becomes whole for the
first time in the entire history of the
universe we finally have a chance of
seeing what was going on
[Music]
is
very few discoveries in science are made
by accident
[Music]
much less the kinds of discoveries that
lead to Nobel prizes instead scientific
progress is typically hard one through
years of commitment incremental research
and investment but in 1978 the Nobel
committee flew in the face of convention
and awarded that Year's Prize in physics
to two men whose groundbreaking
discovery was something of a fluke
it was in the early 1960s in the small
town of Holmdel New Jersey that the
stage was set for the most fortuitous of
discoveries for it was there that the
company Bell Labs had constructed a
20-foot horn-shaped antenna just a few
years after the Great Horn was built a
new satellite system usurped the
original rendering the instrument
obsolete but Bell Labs didn't let their
gigantic hearing aid go to waste instead
they opened it up to researchers Arno
penzius and Robert Wilson who planned to
tune into and analyze the radio signals
coming from the space between galaxies
however when they began their
observations the two astronomers
struggled to make out the signal above a
low but persistent radio hiss
they checked it wasn't coming from
nearby New York City or from local
military installations they confirmed it
wasn't coming from any particular part
of the Milky Way or outside of it but
rather it seemed to be coming from the
entire sky and so for this noise to
appear so consistent and omnidirectional
the researchers concluded it must be due
to some error within the instrument and
indeed when they inspected the antenna
they found it to be home to a number of
roosting pigeons perhaps they're
droppings what they described as a white
dielectric material was giving off heat
that was creating the noise after
several failed attempts to humanely
re-home the birds the researchers
resorted to more drastic measures and
eventually cleared the Horn of both
pigeon and droppings and yet the hissing
still remained penzius and Wilson had
eliminated all possible sources of error
in their instrument and so as a last
resort began to entertain the notion
that this radio noise could in fact be
coming from the entire sky
they reached out to a fellow astronomer
at Princeton University Robert Dickey
for advice and it was Dicky who solved
the mystery in the biggest way possible
he had been developing a theory of atom
formation in the early Universe
believing the Big Bang to be cyclical
all the atoms of a previous Universe
being ripped apart in a scorching
Fireball of compression and reassembled
when the universe expanded and cooled
again this so-called recombination would
turn the cosmos transparent and allow
light to be released for the very first
time in this universe's chronology his
theories predicted that such light
originally in the visible part of the
spectrum as a yellow orange glow could
still be detected at Great distances
within the universe subsequent expansion
of the cosmos would stretch that early
space time until the glow became
red-shifted beyond the perception of our
eyes and into microwave wavelengths
Dickey had planned to search for it
himself but penzius and Wilson had
unwittingly beaten him to it and so a
decade later it was the two Bell lab
researchers who were awarded the Nobel
Prize for the discovery of the so-called
Cosmic microwave background and not
Robert Dickey
regardless of who was credited for
finding or figuring out the cosmic
microwave background and despite
Dickey's cyclical Fireball model being
later ruled out its detection
represented a major turning point for
our understanding of the Big Bang the
discovery of this red-shifted Fireball
glow now stretched out to be just 2.7
degrees above absolute zero is
conclusive evidence that the Universe
did in fact start out in a hot dense
state
even though it dates to a moment some
380 000 years after that moment of
cosmological creation it is Vindication
for our theories of how things unfolded
in the intervening period the earliest
observational evidence we have are the
hot energetic and compact early Universe
even containing within it Clues as to
how the universe will unfold
because while penzias and Wilson found
the microwave hum to be remarkably
consistent across the night sky later
instruments designed to study the CMB
discovered very slight variations places
where it was slightly hotter or cooler
by a few hundred thousandths of a degree
mapping the CMB became a priority for
projects like the cosmic background
Explorer the Wilkinson microwave
anisotropy probe and the Planck
telescope giving rise to incredibly
detailed images of energy and density
variations in the 380 000 year old
universe
and it was those density variations that
provided the seeds for large-scale
structure today since they contained
more matter which then attracted more
matter becoming denser and pulling in
even more and within 100 million years
these over densities had grown massive
enough to trigger the formation of the
first stars and galaxies these
variations seem to be largely random as
would be expected the result of
subatomic Quantum fluctuations inflated
to massive scale through inflation in
the first fraction of a second after the
big bang but closer analysis also
reveals another curious pattern hidden
within the CMB and one that is also
mirrored in the large-scale structure of
the universe today
prior to the formation of atoms when the
universe was still filled with opaque
plasma it was dense enough for sound
waves to pass through it just as sound
travels through the air today these
waves had their origin in conflicting
forces of attraction and repulsion
within the roiling energetic soup as
gravity pulled MATA in towards the
center of denser patches but photons
trapped within that collapsing Maze
rebelled and exerted in outward pressure
upon being packed too tightly and so
these photons pushed back out taking
some of the matter with them spreading
out in three dimensions creating a
complex pattern of concentric ripples as
if from so many raindrops in a pond in a
sense these compressional waves are
sound waves and are therefore known to
cosmologists as baryonic acoustic
oscillations however this phenomenon did
not survive past Atomic recombination
once the universe reached its critical
temperature of 3000 Kelvin Allah
allowing electrons to be captured and
atoms to form the expanding ripples were
suddenly stopped in their tracks as the
photons that were carrying the matter
outwards could now escape unhindered the
baryonic acoustic oscillations were all
Frozen in place they could go no further
and the bunched matter at their
spherical periphery was left stranded
just as the photons had left it
now some 13 and a half billion years
later the universe has expanded but the
pattern left behind by these Frozen
ripples can still be discerned in the
overall structure of Galactic clusters
and superclusters cosmologists find the
baryonic acoustic oscillations in the
modern universe and now roughly 150
megaparsecs or nearly 500 million light
years across and measurements of their
Dimensions at greater distances and
times within the observable Cosmos
provide astronomers with a so-called
standard ruler with which they can
measure the expansion of space
with this information in a universe that
is finally rendered visible to our
instruments we can model how things have
unfolded and predict how things will
unfold in the future
the imprint of the universe's first
light may have already stretched and
dimmed to a shadow of its former self
but it will be trillions of Years yet
before it fades completely from our view
giving cosmologists of the future plenty
of time yet to decipher its Mysteries
a bright twinkle of light ignites in the
Blackness of space
first one then another then a Cascade of
pinpoints light up a cluster grows
swelling in size and gradually
brightening with the light of even more
young stars and within a few billion
years is large enough and massive enough
to begin to spin its own and give the
momentum is enough to stretch it out at
its equator flattening the cluster into
a disc that whirls at more than 200
kilometers per second completing a full
rotation every 250 million years or so
as this young spiral galaxy Wheels
Through extra Galactic space it captures
and absorbs smaller clusters that line
its path head-on collisions with other
spinning galaxies result in mergers
which seed the original spiral with new
material for a frantic burst of star
formation
it is some 10 billion years ago and our
Milky Way galaxy is in the prime of its
life for a few billion years within the
Rippling spiral arms of the Milky Way
massive stars ignite burn furiously and
die dramatically shedding their spent
Fusion fuel back into the galactic Cloud
for recycling this gas is enriched with
the heavier elements that are formed
during Stellar nuclear fusion and
provide the foundation for an entirely
new generation of stars and for the
first time planetary systems late to the
star-forming party on a fragmented
spiral arms on 25
000 light years from the galactic center
one such star sputters into existence
around 4.6 billion years ago and like
the Galaxy itself mirrored on a smaller
scale dust and gas swirl around it in a
flattened disc dust becomes Pebbles
Pebbles become boulders and eventually
Boulders become entire Rocky worlds
these Rocky worlds jostle for a stable
position around the yellow star and
after a few catastrophic collisions
eventually settle into orbits they will
occupy for the next four and a half
billion years
on the third such Rocky World from the
Sun as the heat from its violent
formation dissipates water condenses to
make oceans and atmospheres and plate
tectonics Begins the slow recycling of
rock at the planetary surface somewhere
inside the oceans somehow a spark of
Life ignites Finds Its feet and adapts
and evolves filling this unique world
with an entirely new kind of creation
chemistry becomes biology as a multitude
of life forms swarm the sea land and sky
and then as if from nowhere a sentient
mind appears to contemplate its place in
the universe
[Music]
despite knowing the broad sequence of
events that led to the formation of the
Milky Way galaxy the Sun the Earth life
and us there are still gaps in the
cosmological understanding of our
creation
just how did the lumpy soup of atoms
created a few hundred thousand years
after the big bang lead to all of this
several billion years down the line was
all of it inevitable or could the
universe have followed a different path
taking the matter and energy we know
existed around the time of atomic
recombination and the formation of the
cosmic microwave background and
simulating the subsequent Cosmic
Evolution we end up with a universe that
is subtly but significantly different to
the one in which we find ourselves
there are fewer galaxies less vigorous
star formation and delayed planetary
formation it's possible in these
simulations that life may be lagging
behind or even absent altogether there
is clearly something missing from this
picture one final puzzle piece that
quite literally brings everything
together
unfortunately that missing piece is a
phenomenon that cosmologists simply
can't see
[Music]
380 000 years after the big bang light
has finally escaped its matter prison
photons can travel freely through the
expanding Cosmos but lose energy as it
grows the universe may no longer be
opaque but it is dark the fierce energy
of formation has faded and it will be
millions of years yet before a new
process nuclear fusion comes to
concentrate energy once again these are
the dark ages of the universe and there
may be little to see but this doesn't
mean there is little going on
indeed it is during this time up to and
Beyond the first million years of
cosmological history that scientists
believe Dark Matter steps up to shape
the future of the universe
the existence of Dark Matter was first
considered in 1933 when Swiss astronomer
Fritz ziki was studying the coma cluster
of galaxies some 320 million light years
away from the earth these galaxies seem
to be moving too fast for the cluster to
remain a cluster estimates of the masses
of each galaxy in the cluster based on
the luminous stars that could be seen
encountered gave a number that was some
10 times less than what would have been
needed to keep the group together given
how fast the galaxies were moving to
explain this apparent discrepancy
between the two methods of determining
mass zviki proposed that there must
actually be a lot of unseen Mass lurking
out there amongst the Stars gas and
visible matter he called it Dunkel
materi German for dark matter
in the late 1970s pioneering astronomer
Vero Rubin was studying the rotation of
the Andromeda galaxy the closest spiral
galaxy to our own when she noticed that
something didn't add up in the Motions
of its Stars at the time she and her
colleagues studied cryptic punch card
readouts from their instruments but to
this seasoned astronomer the problem was
as clear as day galaxies were expected
to spin fast close into the center while
Stars at the edges would make a more
stately progression but the punch cards
were telling a different story The Stars
at andromeda's Outer Edge seemed to be
moving just as fast as those in the
central bulge with the tips of its
spiral arms whipping around with
implausible speed the only explanation
for such a movement without violating
the universe's fundamental Laws of
Motion was that the Stars themselves
were only a part of the overall mass of
the Galaxy
Ruben calculated that the visible matter
must represent just 15 percent of what
was really there and that the Andromeda
galaxy must be cocooned in a much larger
Halo of invisible dark matter
subsequent observations revealed that
most galaxies are surrounded in this way
including our own indeed current
estimates suggest that the Milky Way's
Dark Matter Halo could be up to 15 times
larger than the visible extent of its
stars and so astronomers are now
convinced of dark Matter's significance
in shaping the modern Universe despite
our continued inability to detect it
larger scale studies suggest that dark
matter outweighs normal matter six to
one and potentially always has but what
exactly it is remains a mystery even
after several decades of concerted study
one possibility is that the dark matter
in the universe consists of ordinary
objects made up of normal baryonic
matter like quarks and leptons but which
are hard for us to detect with our
current Technologies known as massive
compact Halo objects these are more
often referred to as machos such objects
could be black holes of a wide range of
sizes small but incredibly dense and
massive neutron stars created when giant
Stars collapse at the end of their lives
or an extraordinary number of brown
dwarfs which contain almost as much mass
as a star but not quite enough to ignite
Fusion however as our telescopes and
instruments improve and we are able to
probe the depths of Intergalactic space
in ever more detail the chances of such
objects in sufficient number continuing
to escape our notice grow smaller and
smaller with every passing year because
of this continued lack of observational
evidence an alternative possibility is
currently favored among cosmologists
that the majority of Dark Matter exists
as a weakly interacting massive particle
correspondingly nicknamed wimps
these would be a completely new kind of
particle which would sit outside the
standard model as we understand it today
but which we have so far failed to
detect they would not interact with
normal matter via any of the known
fundamental forces except for Gravity
but would nevertheless have a high mass
or be present in sufficient numbers to
make up for the universe's 85 percent
missing mass and indeed the search is on
in particle accelerators and out in the
cosmos for any hint of these heavyweight
wimps but with so little to go on we may
have a long road ahead of us
regardless of whether dark matter is a
macho or a wimp or something else
entirely it's likely that it has always
been around sitting in the shadow of
tangible matter since its Creation in
the universe's first few fractions of a
second and it was back in the cosmic
Dark Ages around a million years after
the big bang that it began to shape the
overall structure of the universe the
cosmic microwave background suggests
that matter and energy were distributed
unevenly at the moment of atomic
recombination and so we can expect that
dark matter followed suit but in these
darkened Millennia all that mass comes
into its own gravity pulls the Dark
Matter together clumping it more quickly
and more thickly than we'd expect the
baryonic matter to Collapse by itself
the normal matter then has a dark matter
template to follow and is sucked into
invisible gravity Wells thus creating
Cosmos spanning filaments no foods and
clusters of gas that will become the
nurseries for the first stars and
galaxies and from this point on the
evolution of the universe we see today
has become inevitable
everything that has happened up to this
point spanning the first million years
of the cosmic chronology has set the
stage for the next several billion years
of astrophysical creation the universe
has called to a point to a
comprehensible physics whole sway the
four forces have settled and become
distinct determining all fundamental
interactions and the nature and
quantities of matter have settled to
provide the ingredients for generations
of stars and galaxies the Genesis of
chemistry and the ultimate creation of
life
but that is not quite all
for 8 billion years events in the
universe unfold just as we would expect
them to with these basic ingredients but
between five and six billion years ago
not long before the formation of our
solar system within the Milky Way
something changed
and discovering that something 25 years
ago made it clear that we still don't
really understand the balance of the
universe
this disturbing change in the evolution
of the universe was first recognized in
1998 when astronomers were studying
supernovae at different points in space
and time supernovae of a certain size
are sometimes known as standard candles
because they explode with a known and
predictable brightness and Luminosity as
a result they have become valuable tools
for measuring Cosmic expansion since
their light will be stretched into
redder wavelengths with the expansion of
the space between them and our
instruments but astronomers noticed that
for the last 5 billion years or so the
supernovae are more redshifted than they
should be and so have been moving away
from us faster than they should a
pattern that can also be seen in
measurements of baryonic acoustic
oscillations and Galaxy clusters not
only that but the accelerated expansion
itself seems to be accelerating
foreign
explanation for this most recent phase
change of the universe is dark energy
and so for the entire history of our
solar system we have been living in a
dark energy dominated era as with dark
matter cosmologists still don't have a
good idea of what Dark Energy actually
is when Einstein was formulating his
theory of general relativity he
introduced the idea of the cosmological
constant representing the intrinsic
energy of empty space as space expands
there is objectively more of this energy
which could serve to drive further
expansion in the end general relativity
didn't need this modifying constant but
the idea has found new life in
explaining away dark energy
the problem remains however that we do
not understand why such an intrinsic
energy should be present at all if the
explanation cannot be found when
searching on Cosmic scales perhaps the
physics of the very small holds a clue
quantum theory predicts a phenomenon
known as vacuum energy in which the
virtual particles that spring
spontaneously into and out of existence
due to random Quantum fluctuations exert
a pressure causing expansion it is a
promising idea but calculations that
apply this vacuum energy to larger
scales come out far too high to properly
explain the expansion that we see some
cosmologists are considering something
entirely different a new kind of energy
field called quintessence which acts in
the opposite way to normal matter and
normal energy can either be attractive
or repulsive and can change its Behavior
over time but without experiments or
observations that can easily probe that
force or even confirm its existence we
are left stranded in the Dark As Time
Ticks by and the space surrounding us
expands
[Music]
and so whatever it is we're left with a
universe that is approximately 68
percent Dark Energy 27 percent dark
matter and less than five percent
normal matter
and it is from these ingredients that
our universe has grown and developed
over 13.8 billion years following the
rules and constants that were evident in
its very first moments in the first 10
tradicilianths of a second after
the Big Bang
[Music]
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like And
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think as we venture past the
first million years of the universe
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time
foreign